yeah that we left off there was one of
reading that question again yeah I
thought was a good question and this is
from Kevin Pulido again and he said
according to the theory of multiverse
what is this what is space and he says
I'll call it space between universes
what is the space between universes yeah
it's a higher dimension
next question missing all right actually
there's a fifth dimension in there
somewhere but with if you take the three
dimensionality of our universe and then
you embed it among other universes and
another kind of space that's a higher
dimension and in fact I hosted a panel
on nothing nothing at my host
institution the American Museum of
Natural History and we talked about what
is between galaxies if the multiverse
produces galaxies and that's a kind of
nothing but it turns out is not that
that's nothing that you can come up with
it's like the dark alleys of the unit no
because that still has dimensions is it
nothing there's nothing there but it
still has a dimensionality say we got
really deep I mean heads were exploding
left and right yeah give me I don't like
now yeah so so no it's it's the it's
what you would call the space of a
higher dimension which is not even our
space because it would not have the
matter it would not have the energy it
would not have the anything that we
associated with our stuff or even with
with where our stuff isn't because
outside of our universe there's not even
the nothing of space well no well
because if space is nothing then where
there is no space there's not even that
nothing okay nice one okay I'm sorry I'm
not allowed to call this one all right
go for it go for engines what oh go for
it ah okay Evelyn Martin oh it doesn't
wrong with you because you can't imagine
higher dimensions that the ones in which
we are embedded I imagine hard
dimensions but here's a way I'll help
you out I'll hook you up ready are you
so you take an ant and put them on a
piece of paper and then draw a box
around the end just with a with a
sharpie all right and say ant you can't
leave the page all right and so you just
tell that to the end the answers okay
and so the ant walks around you
the this line that you drew and it can't
get past it and it's a prisoner in your
sheet of paper surrounded by this square
drawn by your sharpie because the ant is
embedded as part of the two-dimensional
world you're just created for it and you
and you can say well just escape I can't
escape just jump out of the page step
over the line and go back into the page
and the ant says I don't know what out
of the page means this is my universe so
now I put you in prison surrounded not
by a square that was containing the amp
I surround you by a cube six walls and
you see I can't get out but from a
higher dimension that person is it just
step out into the higher dimension step
back in and you've escaped and you see I
have no idea what you're talking no no I
actually do and supply the pictures move
in Hogwarts because they can step out of
there didn't you step out of your
dimension and then the walls no longer
contain you oh yeah
so you step out of our dimension you get
to see things you would not otherwise
have even known were there perhaps even
the multiverse itself
next question Leanne I look but I don't
bask in that but I'm fine basking
doesn't work on radio no it doesn't